please check out my film generation um  24 hours in the lives of three New York  City friends John Mia and violet whose  relationship takes an unexpected and  intimate turn that could change their  lives you just get to a point where your  disappointment in yourself becomes so  much bigger than your parents  disappointment you how old are you  anyway  come on keep this stuff to myself do you  think Jonah's hot bro you got to grab  that bogey out where you can before some  other dumbass grabs it away from you  you're so stupid  Lizzy wants to know if you would like to  little party tonight John is that a  camera let me ask you a question ask the  question if you were to take a look of  the people you've been intimate with I'm  not discussing that being totally  confusing welcome to my life  it gets worse when you get older  [Music]  you